i love that this friendship is still
going strong
reality tv cameras might not be involved
in it anymore but it's a real true
relationship
we go together together yes
i mean but it's it's not the norm a lot
of times people leave the show and it's
like they never existed in these
people's lives so what's the secret here
oddly enough when eva came
on the show you know we were kind of
pitted against each other i'm 33
she's 51. oh excuse me
she been doing this thing for a long
time show us a veteran walk
i'm not the better one show us how they
use
i don't know at the end of the day you
know this is sunflower i'm loving like
i think the energy just kind of overrode
like any of the um
that was yeah on that way and i just
felt her spirit and i i
liked her i always liked her we've come
full circle honestly
i love to see it i mean eva have you had
any fomo
not filming i know the season is almost
wrapped um
you know what it's been really a cool
adjustment for me you know i think
corona
virus hit the entire country and world
um
at a rapid space and i'm so used to
traveling for business
so for me the opportunity to kind of sit
down
and just enjoy my family enjoy my kids
and
enjoy my man enjoy my relationship with
cynthia that's not just work
i say thank you bravo and thank you
housewives for bringing me
my girls yeah this little tribal women
that you get to
share life with i know you probably
can't say a whole lot about the new
season but we do know there's another
season coming you guys have filmed it
during this crazy time
how do you feel about season 13 i feel
good about it you know it's going to be
a very
different season you know cobit again
changed everything for
how you shoot a reality show as well you
guys will see us shooting a lot more at
homes
we're not out and about as you know as
much as we used to be
obviously we won't be going on a
fabulous international trip this year
so oh wow i didn't even think about that
no we went on a road trip recently um
you know like five hours down the road
yeah you know no i mean i kind of had my
sights on you know maybe the maldives
somewhere but that's not going to happen
we get tested for cobit every week once
a week
religiously there's like super straight
quarantining
rules if you do get on a plane you know
it's just different you know we're in
the movement black lives matter
um i think for the most part a lot of
the women
you know want to try to be more positive
and uplift each other instead of tearing
each other down
you know what i'm saying um so with that
said
it'll be a different season but you know
there's still some drama and
i can just say in my girls defense they
try
[Laughter]
stay in that positive spirit and to keep
and to continue to lift
each other up throughout the movement
but some of us fell
short honey i'll just say we got some
new blood
i know they haven't been confirmed yet
but the blogs have been reporting a lot
i see latoya ali's name pop
up a lot as being in the center of some
stuff apparently
oh front and center yeah latoya is in
here
in the mix um she's a fun addition to
the show
she has a very interesting life but you
guys see all that play out
but more than anything you know she's a
little spitfire she has a lot to say
she's cute as a button she's a business
woman as well she's so cute
super super super cute so uh yeah
latoya's definitely all up in the mix
and what about drew sedora
oh drew's in the mix as well drew kind
of got a little bit of a late start with
some issues that she was having but you
guys will see all that play out as well
but now she's very much in the mix now
and um you know she's an amazing lady
she has a great family
uh mike and ralph are actually really
good friends so
that's kind of like how drew and i ended
up connecting and also through eva
i met um drew at my wine cellar opening
where
mike proposed to me i think drew is also
an amazing addition to the show as well
eva you're not you're not a main cast
member your fingerprints are apparently
all over the season like i literally
have to stop myself from like it's like
oh i have to do this
oh i need to call even like he was not
over here right now
so i it took me some adjusting to
realize that i wasn't gonna be shooting
season 13 with eva i think
uh but we didn't miss a beat and though
we haven't shot
together when it especially considering
the pandemic and all that's going on
it's been nice just being able to
support cynthia
while she's going through and just be a
friend
and not really get into the mix of it
all
and just enjoy candy kenya right now in
brooklyn she's at the most
adorable age her and mikey are so great
together so
it's kind of secret
yeah you get to be a part of all the the
nice things and not
in the in the mess you know bus read off
you know why
because this year there's so much going
on especially
with racial tension um with black lives
matter
and i think that it's going to be a fine
line trying to figure out
how to keep the focus of the movement
and then not derail and get into the
drama and so
i just commend the girls and the women
this season
for putting their big girl panties on
getting out here working
still entertaining but not forgetting
what we're trying to do and what really
matters right now and so
my hat goes off to them but i will say
you know kudos to the ladies like
like on the positive note on the
positive tip they have definitely all
stepped up
everyone stepped up in their own way to
really just support the movement
you know to support black people black
excellence in every way that they can
just trying to be a part of making you
know the world a better place especially
in regards to
to black people yeah it's been pretty
inspiring to see how porsche has really
stepped up yeah horses
you know come full circle and uh we are
all very proud of
the way that she stepped up i mean she
literally was on the front lines like
she was out there
when you know some of us was like oh
[ __ ] is it safe to go out yet
like you know but um you know eventually
like i said everyone was able to find
their way that they wanted to support
the movement and you know we we all
you know all of it matters you know all
of it works together
so um yeah portia is
doing her thing all right we gotta talk
the big news coming out of real
housewives of atlanta
lenithia leaks miss nene leaks saying
goodbye to the show
after more than a decade when you heard
the news what was your reaction
i was surprised i think
you know you always have to give nene
her props just in terms of
you know being one of the first being on
the forefront of the show
helping to create the platform so that
someone like myself and eva
could be a part of it she's great for
the show i've always thought she was
great for the show even when we weren't
friends and she was
coming from my my wig i still thought
she was good for the show
so with that said i reached out to her
and i just you know i was just kind of
sad watching
her leave and and i think what's
happening now is i just
always felt like you know everything
comes to an end at some point i've been
on this show for 11 years
i don't know how long i'm going to be on
the show in a perfect world when i
when when i decide to leave or whenever
they decide to fire me over
get rid of me or whatever you want
whatever's going to happen
um i just hope that for me personally
that i can look back on this experience
and
just appreciate the journey i just wish
nene well
i just want her to be happy she's a
strong woman i know that from being
friends with her for many years we have
not seen the last of her
you know i i wish people would just
allow her the process
you know maybe she doesn't have to do it
on social media you know maybe she could
kind of take it in and just go through
what she's going through but she's
entitled to that process
it must really be you know
hard to not be over here for whatever
reasons
they are because i don't really know the
reasons i just know that she's not and
i've been
watching along with everyone else and it
does make me sad because i know
she's you know she has a good heart and
i know how hard she works
and i know she means well i really know
that she means well
so that's all evil take it away
ah i think you uh you hit it right
nene is tv gold there have only been a
few
reality stars that you say their name
and they represent an entire franchise
and lenithia monique leaks is that and
so i think reality television i think
weekly television appointment tv is
going to miss her
good bad or indifferent if you like what
she was doing or you didn't like what
she was doing she captivated you
she could definitely put it all out
there on the line um
and in some ways you know so much so and
so transparent that you literally felt
her pain
and at this place where she is i'm
shocked to see her go
and i definitely feel her pain i um
root for her i wish for nothing but the
best and
i hope to see nene back on the screen
where she belongs
because of that lady fun at the end of
the day she's a good side
i like that we've come to that place
because last season did not end in that
place for you guys you guys were not in
the best spot
at the end of last season so to see that
but you know what life is so short
and unless there's really something that
you can't get over unless
it is a bell that cannot be unrung for
me
it's not that deep i have so much love
and light with the friends that i have
around me
and i speak to every day my family and
just let bygones be bygones i was hurt
about what happened
and god has restored my friendships and
others a hundred fold so i'm good
if the pandemic has not taught us taught
us anything it has taught us that life
is too
short like we took so much for granted
before and to the world we took so much
for granted
and when you look back now it's like
really like right if we had it
really is not that deep you know i mean
we can move past it so
which is why i think i made my exit
because it's kind of like
how do you focus on that with all of
this going on in the world
you know for me out here on the radio
trying to
empower the community every day
how do i do that in a way that i ensure
you know the world is going to get the
best version of me
right especially in these times you two
have partnered up for a really
cool thing the seagram's escapes
holiday marketplace talk to me about
this the
sigrum's escape holiday marketplace
initiative
is all about supporting black-owned
businesses copen19
did not do any small businesses any
favors
so with this wow i thought that this
would be amazing
to to use the platform and
for sigrums to partner with me to
support
and and highlight and help promote black
businesses
who are still struggling and the thing
i'm most excited about is the fact that
we will be giving three
business owners ten thousand dollar
grants to support their businesses which
is
huge go to
www.sixscapes.com
holiday shop to sign up to win this ten
thousand dollars
okay for this grant that three winners
and it just would be a nice little gift
to have
to just kind of keep your businesses
going so please make sure you guys go to
the website
and and sign up
you